[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here today we've got
a favorite among the wisecrack staff the
tale of humans picked for experimental
augmentations to find out what happens
when people stop being polite and start
getting real at first look the Deus Ex
franchise is a kind of wet dream for
Infowars enthusiasts murderous plots by
the Illuminati are carried out by world
governments while the player traverses
FEMA camps and discovers the truth
behind fake news but unlike certain
performance artists deus ex is forays
into conspiracy serve as more than just
a means to sell dietary supplements the
game reveals how paranoia informs more
of society's decisions than we'd like to
admit and serves as a cautionary tale
for the dangers of technology to come
but there are no gay frogs
sorry internet welcome to this wisecrack
addition on Deus Ex this video is made
in collaboration with our buddy Joseph
over at real life Lord you can learn
more about his channel and check out his
related video at the end of this one and
if you're here visiting from real-life
floor welcome and be sure to subscribe
and spoilers ahead for all the games the
Deus Ex series asks two basic questions
one what would it mean for society if we
could all become cyborgs with Jack's
arms and two what does the premise that
every conspiracy theory is true mean for
the real world and before we get into
the ethics of skull guns and neural
enhancement we have to put on our
tinfoil hats there's no shortage of
conspiracy theories in the Deus Ex
series in the original game a splinter
organization of the Illuminati called
majestic 12 produces a nanite virus
called the gray death as a means to
consolidate their power why contain it
let it spill over to the schools and
churches let the bodies pile up in the
streets in the end they'll beg us to
save them as producers of the only cure
for the disease as well they can easily
manipulate others while capitalizing off
the disorder wrought by it the gray
death is a man-made virus everyone up to
the president is at únicos mercy as long
as you natkho controls the supply of
ambrosia in the sequel Invisible War the
Illuminati controls two of the most
influential groups in the world
the World Trade Organization and the
order a religious organization opposed
to the WTO by managing the conflict
between these two factions the
Illuminati is better able to control the
world finally in the new prequels we see
the Illuminati attempt to limit human
augmentation since having a bunch of
engineered superhumans running around
isn't really great for the whole
compliant population thing that they're
going for if there's one thread that has
run through these sometimes vastly
different games in the series it's
paranoia not only is there the
conspiracy paranoia but also paranoia
directed at so-called Outsiders and
others ultimately the game's revealed
the profound power of paranoia and that
it doesn't matter whether the paranoia
points to the truth or not paranoia
independent of truth shapes our actions
and ultimately society early on in the
game
goonter your cyborg co-worker who yearns
for a skull gun is convinced that the
facility staff is replacing orange soda
in the vending machines with lemon lime
in an inane and unlikely conspiracy
against him the machine will do not make
a mistake it's the maintenance man he
knows I like orange so you think the
staff has some kind of plot yes except
20 years later in the game sequel it's
revealed in the ruins of Gunter's office
that he was right all along probably
some sort of office as if to foreshadow
the entire rest of the game this idea of
just because you're paranoid doesn't
mean they're not after you becomes the
main ethos of deus ex in mankind divided
colleague spin wild tales of getting
hacked which turn out to be true we have
a lot of enemies the people who bomb the
train station you don't think they'd
love to know where we are you
to help me figure out who's looking into
us and make them stop others suspect a
police cover-up of a bombing they're
probably destroying all the evidence
there is right now also true well I was
right even you the player must navigate
who to trust your old-time boss David
Seraph pilot Alex Vega your new boss at
Interpol who may or may not be working
for the Illuminati at every point the
game undermines your trust in others as
you hack into the emails of your
co-workers install listening devices and
get ambushed by enemies who were tipped
off about your arrival hell even the
suicide cult that wants to merge with
computers and mankind divided turn out
to only be a few years off from being
right JC Denton manages to do this with
Helios at the end of the original Deus
Ex
so why does Deus Ex make a point to
validate even the most far-fetched ideas
it could be in part to tell a greater
message about how paranoia works in the
real world people who are paranoid often
don't invent things out of nothing but
instead take interpretive leaps when
over analyzing the data presented to
them well if you thought he was high
strung before the attack only made him
more manic he's making connections no
one else sees and some that may not be
there but rather than dismissing this
kind of paranoia as mere delusion deus
ex runs with it is a man rambling in the
sewers about mind control right I was
part of it the hive mind inside the gate
I questioned what holds us together
where why unequivocally yes you mean
your attempt to control people
amplifying your hypnotic techniques with
some kind of social enhancer this brings
me to one of mankind divided most
important commentaries tracing the
relationship between general paranoia
and racial paranoia augmented humans as
a metaphor for racial discrimination
isn't exactly subtle as a mechanically
augmented Interpol agent you face
harassment from the citizens of Prague
and literally live on the wrong side of
the tracks as you witness routine police
brutality inflicted on your augmented
peers to understand what fuels this
discrimination we're turning to cigar
enthusiast and psychoanalyst Jacques
Lacan
or at least with the Slovenian
Dumbledore writes about him and for a
Boise check our paranoid theories often
reflect our own identities ideologies
and shortcomings rather than the actual
state of things for instance he cites a
story from Lacan regarding a jealous
husband who even if right that his wife
is sleeping around is still
pathologically jealous if she stays late
at work
he'll pathologically assume she's being
unfaithful if she starts having male
friends same thing as a development of
this logic jiseok cites Nazi
anti-semitism if a Jewish person
committed a crime it could very well be
true but the fixation on Jewish crime
spoke more to German paranoia about
foreigners and pureblood than to any
kind of real issue in other words crime
is just crime until a Jewish person
commits it then it becomes part of the
grand Jewish conspiracy to ruin the
German race and so on you can look at
conspiracy theories in the same light
our most laws made in closed-door
meetings with lobbyists and interest
groups probably are they all part of a
secret cult to serve their reptilian
overlords
probably not likewise in Deus Ex anti
augmentation advocates filter all
information through the lens that
Augmented people are dangerous and
possibly an affront to nature Talking
Heads use terrorism or the catastrophic
agha incident where augmented people
were hacked into going into a homicidal
rage to justify apartheid style
oppression of Augmented people this
discrimination then fuels even more
violence thus making Augmented paranoia
a self-fulfilling prophecy
everyone looking over their shoulder
treat people like animals long enough
they'll start acting like animals the
power of paranoia to shape public
discourse can be seen in Deus Ex Eliza
caissons defense of news coverage meant
to spread fear toward the Augmented is
just reporting the news and even if the
reporting is true her guest points out
the Ogden the news functions on two
levels one as a keen points out to only
report on the negative aspects of
augmented existence and two to use
augmented violence as a validation for
your larger ideological project in this
case the human Restoration Act a bill
that would either remove or severely
limit the augmentations that people have
of course unlike real world news Pike
is's news coverage is dictated by the
Illuminati what
I was engineered to monitor
communications and data streams to find
out what people are talking about and
make sure it's being discussed correctly
as they cover up evidence of water
contamination in Prague and falsely
report that a flight was taken down by
an augment to terrorists
[Music]
rather than the troop that the plane was
shot down by a military installation
plane went down because of whatever the
military was doing there not because of
some augmented passenger like bikers
clamson reject these paranoia's don't
tell us much about reality itself but
instead shine light on the reality
behind the paranoia for Deus Ex that
reality is a carefully constructed story
meant to combat augmentation so that the
Illuminati can better control the
population for their pro-business
purposes but is there an even deeper
truth to the way paranoia operates in
the game while the real world is not
governed by the Illuminati depending on
who you ask one could argue that it is
governed by the basic principle which
the Illuminati in Deus Ex understands
the state of exception according to
philosopher Giorgio Agamben there is a
hidden law that lies behind both modern
liberal democracies and the totalitarian
regimes of the 20th century the
exception we've talked about this before
in our walking dead and attack on Titan
videos but Deus Ex is exploration is
wholly unique a gun ban builds off the
theory of sometimes right but always an
[ __ ] Karl Schmitt who argued that
what defines sovereignty is not the law
per se but the ability to suspend the
law to make the exception for agamben
this suspension of law marks all
totalitarian regimes the concentration
camps were a physical space where normal
law was suspended for more than a decade
a state of exception
whereas our modern liberal democracies
aren't building death camps the state of
exception is an always imminent
component of modern governance usually
in the name of a national emergency or
an existential threat governments today
regularly create zones of exception
where the law no longer applies or
creates classes of people who are
outside the normal functioning of the
law and thus exist in this kind of
exceptional state prisoners of war
protected by international law get
replaced by enemy combatants who get
sent to Gitmo where regular US law
doesn't apply in Deus Ex this logic
seems implicit to the conspiracy theory
favorite FEMA in the name of managing
emergencies they build detention camps
for political prisoners and implement
martial law be segregated you delight
complex of mankind divided presents a
similar zone of exception
it resembles a mix of apartheid-era
South Africa Jewish ghettos the kowloon
walled city and modern-day refugee camps
the player witnesses horrifying examples
of police ality and augmented people who
live in constant fear all in the name of
security and when tensions boil over
such as when an Augmented rights
activist is assassinated the civil
unrest justifies even more repression if
the Illuminati wants to spread chaos
like staging a train station bombing
it's because they understand that chaos
breeds people desiring security and when
people desire security it's all the
easier to suspend basic rights and exert
more Authority while we may think of
chaos and order as opposites the game
understands how they can become
entangled in the modern world chaos is
manufactured in discrete ways in order
for oppressive powers to maintain
control but besides illuminating no pun
intended how security operates even in
our own non Illuminati world Deus Ex
also uses the state of exception as just
one of its many criticisms of
transhumanism transhumanism is the idea
that technology will help us overcome
human limitations like disease and
scarcity prosthetics contact lenses and
in vitro fertilization are just stepping
stones in the greater transhumanist
project transhumanism is baked into the
very idea of human augmentations ASX
however rather than blindly celebrating
transhumanism it portends everything
that could possibly go wrong as the
human race unlocks human potential and
mastery over nature that technology
becomes available to individuals and
groups and can potentially fall into the
wrong hands
even augmentation technology developed
by the Illuminati soon escaped their
control as private corporations entered
the fray this forced the Illuminati to
change their stance and oppose
augmentation now by going public with
this discovery Seraph is forcing our
hand Invisible War starts with a
terrorist attack that turns everything
into a grey goo and in mankind divided
there exists an underground market for
augmentations which is likely assisting
both the good guys and bad guys as such
the destructive
potential of technology often
necessitates permanent states of
emergencies and martial law that a
Gambon's work was critical of basically
as technology gets to epoch the
government will have little problem
convincing you that your rights have to
be suspended for the good of everyone
but it's not just the state of exception
that's a problem for the transhumanist
future JBS Haldane one of the earliest
thinkers of transhumanism warned in 1924
that society would have a hard time
keeping pace with the progress of
Technology in Daedalus or science in the
future he wrote that the tendency of
applied science is to magnify in
Justices until they become too
intolerable to be born and the average
man whom all the prophets and poets
could not move turns at last and
extinguishes the evil at its source in
other words technology will make social
injustice is worse until societal anger
will boil over into a full-on rage in
Deus Ex more often than not the dangers
of Technology are thrust upon the poor
those who are augmented need to
constantly take neuropathy to stop their
body from rejecting their augmentations
but those with means can much more
easily obtain the expensive drug and in
the case of manual laborers or soldiers
who are augmented by their employers let
me guess who's the laborers were
augmented with heavy duty industrial
groups or the government send you what
they want make you do what they want
replace parts of you whenever and
however they want they exist in a
precarious state where the maintenance
of their augmentations is contingent on
them maintaining the same or similar job
rather than suggesting that human
evolution through technology will level
the playing field
Deus Ex suggests societal forces will
make inequality worse
and just as Haldane warns that this
tension will cause people to rise up and
root out evil at its source we see two
competing movements in the game focused
on the same thing in human Revolution
the humanity front uses violence to stop
the spread of augmentation and in
mankind divided a legal solution exists
in the human Restoration Act meanwhile
augmented people slowly entertain
violence as a political strategy and
tell the assassination of Talos Rucker
results in full-on riot you know word of
ruckus
is going to spread don't you and when
that happens the head of State Police
assures me golem City will become a war
zone
another idea trumpeted by some
transhumanists is the idea of the
singularity a point at which artificial
intelligence will explode the rate of
technological development in the
original Deus Ex Bob Page hopes to
create his own twisted version of this
by merging with the Helios AI but
instead the player is given the option
to merge with Helios to rule the post
singularity world as a benevolent
dictator the game doesn't necessarily
put any kind of judgment on this but the
solution still feels a bit icky and
afterwards when the merger between JC
Tenten and Helios doesn't go as planned
the technological infrastructure of the
world collapses and chaos envelops the
world the message is not so subtly found
in the name of the to a is that usher in
the singularity Daedalus and Icarus the
barriers between us have fallen we have
become
I don't share those according to legend
Daedalus was an ancient Greek inventor
who invented man-made flight his son
Icarus plummets to his death
after using the invention to fly too
close to the Sun the collapse can be
viewed in this light as a too fast and
too reckless technological development
that comes metaphorically crashing down
Haldane believed the only hope is for
morality to keep pace with science Deus
Ex explores the moral questions inherent
in our technology driven future is it
right for companies to augment their
workers instead of asking this
beforehand the prevailing logic in the
game is augment first ask questions
later
what about installing ships to limit a
person's augmentation if they say go on
a homicidal rage a brief debate may
happen on TV while legislators are
trying to pass the bill but companies
have already developed the technology
before anyone decides whether this
technology should even exist technology
first morality later and that's a recipe
for disaster in a way day s X is forcing
us to ask these questions we can find
Talos Rucker offering a robust criticism
of governments limiting the abilities of
the Augmented and even though we're a
bit far from Jack's arms the games can
make us question the technological
progress in our own world
[Music]
they on disaster like this would get a
lot of press in foreign aid but given
that these are social media has
radically redefined how we engage with
the world and we've only begun to ask
questions about its influence after we
suspect it's done something egregiously
wrong so what do you think wisecracking
well arch like Deus Ex convinced us to
take a critical look at technology
before we decide to universally adopt it
or are we diving headfirst into a
nightmare and one more question in a
world where people trying to secede in
places like Texas Catalonia and even
California seems to be getting more
popular the original deus ex seems
weirdly prophetic there's the national
secessionist forces and Texas's troubled
attempt to leave the union
but how would that actually work our
friend joseph at real life floor has a
great video exploring the hypothetical
secession of texas where he and i are
from so go check out his video by
clicking here and be sure to tell them
that wisecrack sent you and as always
guys thanks for watching peace
[Music]